i read the book i feel like can i wear
these oh yeah you're probably cooler
than them
god damn yeah you look like a wrestler
man
you look like you about to just dive off
the top rope swanton look like you're
about to do a ted talk on rice krispie
treats
get your life don't touch me together
i'm not touching you dude
you know he gets the most hate drake
drake yeah
drake wins but he does but i'm mine he's
you're saying i'm kind of like drake
you're the jewish drake i'm saying drake
might be jewish well i'm saying both
y'all are like drake
drake is you guys together he's black
and jewish we're drake well hold on
yeah on the cool side yeah why is black
the cool side just because of the blind
that's right they're just like yeah
you're cool right now i admit it you're
cooler than me
dude this is like heaven yeah this is
like dividing drake we could hold hands
and then we were i don't know
hands because i heard a lot of women
watch the show oh man
i think this would be the closest we're
gonna get to having drake on the show
that's why we
i'm the rapper all right i'll sing okay
hell yeah okay so you're the rap insider
you're the second son
sure he's marvin's room
i'm 4 p.m in dallas oh damn running i
don't know the reference
i don't understand it well it's a drake
song oh that's fine
well 6 p.m i don't listen around this
tiger dang man damn we got a
real [ __ ] fest up in here dude i know
real
kind of i i said i said to brendan i
said hey brenden let's get to let's try
some get some different people in
and the culture corner you get more men
man dude
we look like a boy band no direction
are those gucci glasses uh are they what
are those
yeah they're gucci be cool all right
they're cool though cool britney
brandon looks like the accountant for
like a male sex trafficking group
you look like a guy that comes and tells
people if rainbows are uh
to uh [ __ ] i can't
i'm not your outfit today though doug oh
you look at the guy
that comes in here shows up and tells if
rainbows are to specifications or not
you're like yeah this rainbow checks
right here yeah yeah i'm gonna just do
the drake ad-lib every time y'all say
something like yeah
is that what jake does yeah he does does
he yeah yeah he does that
yeah he totally does that i am not i'm
not not a drake fan but i don't know
enough about him i have to read up on
him a little
his music is fantastic you know he's a
child actor
oh yeah he didn't grow up like thug he
grew up like
he was a child well i remember yeah his
one of his lyrics in the beginning was
like he borrowed his uncle
car that was like the toughest thing
that happened to him and he had it back
late
and grabbed the back yeah and and then
he parked the rolls royce and the driver
degrassi and he was in a wheelchair on
the show of course he was
jimmy he was jimmy oh he's playing
handicap he's playing handicapped
progress he's a basketball player
they shot him in the hallway that's
right in his back right yeah in his back
yep
jimmy and then he did he's in a
wheelchair and then he has the same late
legs as malik wait what time i wait wait
wait a minute
wait
i think that they're like that or no uh
uh
what's that australian shepherd oh they
have little skinny legs they got bad
legs yeah
can you look that up australian shepherd
dysplasia hip dysplasia
i don't think that no those dogs are
super athletic
there you go oh yeah oh yeah i could be
there
that's the dog drake right there wow
dog how was nashville nashville was nice
man
it was really it was awesome went
swimming um
many country folk oh yeah everybody
trying to be a cowboy out there
everybody trying to be luke bryant
people real kind yeah well there's like
a mix the city is pretty
uh it's not as country but i think once
you get outside yeah you see people's
country
and country music now especially with
the the dudes who do it it's a little
bit they're like
country [ __ ] boys they wear the hats
they get the tight jeans
yeah it's a little less country a little
more [ __ ] boy i've gone ahead and tight
jeans right now so
yeah well you're part you're in
nashville now doug in nashville
yeah maybe i'm just a [ __ ] boy there i
am right there with that little man
right there okay there it is
and that was the only dark guy in
nashville right there was that dude
i love how the butt the shirt is on you
and uh darius rucker
that little guy's in nashville yep ari
did we ever go there when we were torn
or no
that was like the one place we didn't go
but i'd like to
i should have came out with you i want
to go everywhere with you
dude look he's at a road warrior man
remember when we left you at that gas
station on accident
that's not how i remember it but
you guys rented an rv or something like
a tour bus yeah we saved money by
cutting out a tour bus and we got a
camper
i slept in it and then he slept in a
hotel because he's a [ __ ]
well or because i'm a guy that can
afford it yeah
um yeah no there was one day where we
were filming b-roll of the camper
driving by
and they just kept driving by when i was
outside filming the b-roll so then i had
to run
down the street it's an interesting
sweat on a freeway yeah it was a freeway
they made me run down the side of a
freeway to catch up to the camper
[Applause]
it hurt my feelings actually did it yeah
well i've never known you a to have
feelings honestly the entire time i've
known you
straight very hard to find this but you
just got a van though didn't you
i bought a big white van with a high
room
during this climate dude it's uh i just
decided to lean
into being a white male comic and i just
went with the van
it's beautiful i mean it's scary 2000's
20 years old
78 000 miles paid 10 grand for it i'm
converting it into a camper
i'm just going to go around the country
and just meet people make it into a
church man i would make it into a small
church
how many people can get in it i think
you could probably fit 12 to 15 people
oh yeah that's a youth group yeah you
got this
boy scouts are you guys into the first
service nope hard pass
i'll be in shotgun and your plans just
to explore the united states
kind of just go where the wind takes me
i don't have any set plans
just i was thinking go on instagram and
make a post who wants me to come out
there with my van
and then just follow that how are you
going to make money and pay for gas and
[ __ ]
singing without just texting you guys
for what chat
you guys i feel like have a little bit
of extra money and you could fund this
and get involved on the ground floor
this is a great pitch
dude well you know you'll enjoy it if
you're starting up a church
group maybe you'll enjoy seeing me in my
travels so the return is kind of an
emotional return
this is shark tank i feel like yeah and
i'm gonna go and pass
[Laughter]
this is a bad episode of shark tank this
is shark
tank this is minnow tank i just feel
like it'll make you feel good
seeing me feel good and that's a return
sorry i'm so disappointed
with me but now are you been breaking
the boundaries uh for
oh sorry no on the camper thing um
that'd be a hard time
yes think about it you don't need to
decide right now just sleep on okay let
me see tomorrow yeah
the last thing i want to do is leave out
of this room with any increments of this
idea in my head
so all right definitely no you'll have
to figure something out buddy
i'm kind of riding a lot on this pitch
yeah so i'm gonna have to think about it
you did seem a little nervous walking in
the studio because you had this like
whole pitch planned out we're gonna
throw this one back and let it grow a
little
okay okay uh yeah what was i gonna ask
you about
what else did you say something he said
he's getting pretty deep into
the dark web oh you've been
dating all over social distancing lines
haven't you
i've been not keeping social justice i'm
an anti-covet guy
okay and i know you had coronavirus so
you're probably
in agreement with me uh when you say
anti-corona what do you i need
we just gotta live our lives yeah i
agree with that yeah yeah just go out
there listen i'm not 80.
i don't want to stay inside and when
yeah when someone tells me they don't
want to meet
up with me i'm just like grow up see ya
so
so are you meeting these women on tinder
where you come out grinder mostly
dm'ing i dm a lot of people i like that
oh wow
and then do you say you don't know
that's around the pond too well yeah it
talks about
frowned upon it just depends what age
they are it's risky
they're adults as far as i know yeah
okay and yeah i dm them say what's up
make some small talk get to know them a
little bit and then i say well you want
to
get some food or something and then or
something like are you out of your mind
yeah some people blocked me right away
yeah you gotta do indoor people but
that's how i know that one's not the
love of my life
because the love of my life wouldn't
block me or something like that dude the
crazy thing is though this is why i
don't know if you can have a love of
your life sometimes and
and i i care about you but um you don't
blink a lot whenever you talk
because i have one really good secretion
of
[Laughter]
it makes me think sometimes when people
don't blink at all forever
well just not they're going to find the
love of their life
it's kind of a red flag hey i can't wait
to meet the love of my
life
you know what girls like one thing they
like eye contact they like
intense eye contact passionate i think
there's a level to that though you know
right
[Laughter]
um what about you you've been crossing
the social uh also we're in here with
ari manus and malik i don't know malik's
last name oh malik b malik
what do i need to introduce myself or
does the b stand for anything or is it
it stands for bravery
that's awesome i mean it depends on who
asking the question bravery wilson
last week you totally stood for
basketball
[Laughter]
well yeah that's true we had a girl
bravery wilson at our school when i was
growing up a great name
was pretty cool is that native american
what bravery yeah no my real lives
the b stands for brazil like my last
name like it's creole yeah mom
yeah oh he's oh he's from louisiana oh
you are yeah oh nice
where did you go to high school up there
uh i went to tara high school in baton
rouge louisiana oh wow
and then i moved hurricane katrina then
i moved to l.a
yeah okay yeah okay government airline
highway yeah okay i got you i thought
you said he lives
off the government no no well i knew i
knew that
i might now that's a low blow
this is the guy with a grateful dead
he owns a successful landscaping company
right now yeah
he's got all checked out everybody from
the neighborhood i grew up in who's a
successful lady
you couldn't see the landscaping or
pressure washing that was the big thing
bro if you wanted to get out of my
room you had to get a pressure washer
bruh sometimes i remember you see
somebody get a pressure washer for
christmas eve like oh
[ __ ] you know ronnie made it
all right ronnie's you're balling
wash his way to his dreams
[Laughter]
pressure wash is not a bad business you
get because it's only about a thousand
dollars for a good machine and then you
can make money fast
no not a huge overhead you can kind of
do it anywhere right water use their
water you hook up the hose
unless they make you bring your own
water yeah people always need
[ __ ] wash that's messed up because my
dad was a painter he always had a
pressure washer
really yeah young age like yeah yeah
yeah yeah
he scared the hell out of me but i got a
good grip now for things like
that oh damn yeah that's cool man so if
you're getting a gun play or anything
and i'm not
this isn't any kind of racial profiling
thing but if you get into gun play
you're the guy yeah you got that well i
don't know how to aim right because i
never had a dad to teach me
oh but you know how to wash right yeah
no
yeah of course yeah spraying houses i'm
the guy
damn yeah my dad was a a contractor
painter
do a drive-by washing that would be
insane let me do it
allison just like hop on just wash
people's cars for free not like bees
drive by washing you just roll up and
just
but is anybody gonna like you know call
the police on me
oh yeah oh wait wait wait no wait i
don't like that that's always a risk
wait no i want a future
yeah well i mean you have to go
somewhere else for that
all right i can't guarantee that in
america right now just climbing
yeah i'm busy yeah spraying stuff yeah i
should get a shirt and say spray [ __ ]
man you gotta get fresh bro dude i've
been fresh man i'm feeling hello
oh dang get fresh dude yellow fresh
or bienvenidos con fresca yeah dog i'm
talking about pre-measured ingredients
and mouth-watering
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
door
hello fresh i know you are man and one
thing that it is
and look people say man i've heard you
guys talk about this and i don't know
and this and that my mouth's not
watering yeah well look because you're
not thinking about it
like we're thinking about it yep how are
we thinking they send you a box
inside of the box it's in the box oh
i'll tell you
what's in the box dude it's that
freaking red
split of amazing foods man you somewhat
some of the recipes will have like a
onion
uh um some pork yeah a different glaze a
demi-glaze man hellofresh offers so many
recipes to choose from
each week to help you break out your
recipe right man there's something for
everybody including low calorie
vegetarian family-friendly recipes every
week it's fun
step outside of your comfort zone you
open up the box you get one of the
recipes and you make it with the kiddo
yeah make it with the 30 minutes bro
some even 20 minutes
make it with you inside do whatever man
and we have a discount for you right now
you you will enjoy it if you've never
tried it i promise you you will not
not enjoy it yeah your mouth will be
water in no time all you got to do
is go to hellofresh.com80cats
use the code eight zerocats to get a
total of eighty dollars off
including free shipping on your first
box additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com for more details
again that's hellofresh.com
slash eight zero k a t s and use code
eighty cats
to get a total of eighty dollars off
including free shipping on your first
box
this episode is brought to you by
manscape
and heavy on the man yeah we got a bunch
of dudes in here
it's a brosie episode dude i wanted to
call manscape like everybody in here
needs manscape
chin's looking more like that one of the
hottest chicks i've seen
ever in a while you'll be in studio for
a while yeah chin's starting to look
real proper man well look speaking of
getting things looking proper manscaped
is what i'm saying to you
manscape scape up your manhood yeah dude
you have the lawnmower bro well it's
part of the perfect package it's the
it's the perfect package from manscape
it'll have your hairless balls
really just feeling welcome yeah you
don't have to nick them no more and
that's not bleeding anymore they just
released their sheer 2.0 nail kit you
got some long nails what are you doing
what are you doing what are you
scratching people what are you trying to
do you're trying to live up a tree
the shears 2.0 damn that perfect package
also gives you the manscape crop
preserver the anti-chafing ball
deodorant and moisturizer
oh yeah you can tone up those testicles
man take care of your body no more swamp
ass son
oh take care of it trim your ass trim
your buddy's ass man yeah
help each other out man get 20 off and
free shipping with the code
king sting at manscape.com that's right
20
off and free shipping with the code king
sting at
manscaped.com it's 20 off with free
shipping
at manscape.com and use code king sting
make sure your gang gang is buzz buzz oh
damn with the landscape i'd still invest
in that business over aries though
wow oh the debate dude when you see him
pressure washington's not going to make
you happy it's not going to bring you
joy it's going to make you five dollars
you know you need a good outfit i think
while you wash though did you ever
did you want to be a washer well my dad
my dad had this all white like overalls
overalls and shirt and he had like 10
boots and he was very dark
my people used to make fun of like your
dad look like a lit cigarette so i used
to get mad and i'll take a good one
i know i used to get mad i felt like d
change your outfit never did so i just
dude
here's my idea for it just spitballing
ideas okay you do
have a lot of ball and all right
here's the thing you do overalls no tea
underneath oh that's
how the back out yeah okay get get get
the traps out for the ladies
okay that's a good point yeah okay i'll
watch it right now thunder down
underneath
thunder down under 300 underpaid uh
washing business
okay there it is yeah spray women houses
for free
no not for free now no no no this is
where the jewish guy got
nothing professional partner up on this
yeah now i'm into it you guys should
partner up
okay this is shark tank now okay this is
why we need partnerships
of different cultures drake's car
washing business great car washes yeah
but what about that and our first
thundering under can be our business
card
you guys play drake and wash cars at the
same time now that would be fire
you take your shirt off i'll take my
shirt i could take my shirt off
leave it on dude i mean some girls like
dad bonds that's true
or people not just girls do you have the
dad bob what kind of butt do you have do
you think
yeah it's like skinny fat guy it's like
a father figure
do you have kids though do you have kids
no not yet i'd like to have three of
them
[Laughter]
dude you have to blink when you say
something like that you can't
i'm serious bro and i love you but if
you don't blink when you say something
it just
seems like you want to steer to not have
them like
it's weird to force blinks too because
then it doesn't feel natural like i want
to have three of them
yeah that's a little weird yeah but it
works a little better
still less creepy that's always picking
out a burlap sack out of the back of his
van
i want three kids by the end by midnight
tonight
yeah he has a lindenburg baby shirt on
yeah came over the crib
we got that little pf chang's heavy on
the chains oh yeah that's true man we've
been really cultural this weekend we had
pf changs
let's watch some fights yeah watch some
fights and uh what was that bellator
we're watching no ufc ufc
yeah tiger tiger and you [ __ ] oh you
had to play with burning sun man
we actually got some footage you guys in
the backyard some cats in the wild here
okay oh [ __ ]
there's brendan with the wig
[ __ ] is that us are you guys starting a
competing business yeah
hold on back to dope
oh wow the boys are living you guys were
i'm jack
oh these guys must be rich huh where do
they live at
that really does look like me noises the
boys are dope
i'm with it i'm with it um
you've been doing shows have you have
you guys been either y'all been doing
shows during this
uh with brandon oh that's right you guys
went on the road to
the arizona went arizona was it normal
super you know what a little too normal
that's probably why you got covered all
right
i don't have to show this i don't
understand why this is uh what's this
well this is this is when you kind of
like i didn't know what i was doing
oh you posted this well i just want to
show like don't ever be afraid to attack
the bear that's what i wanted
who's the bear dude here's here's the
thing
you got to drive with your legs man you
gotta hang them on the wall who filmed
this
yeah i don't know i guess kevin
kevin is not i know
kevin would never work here this is
insane it's hard to see who's winning it
i was winning up top and then when he
dropped the camera that's when you kind
of like
bring it to home but here's the thing
there they keep
[ __ ] with me and then hopefully
wrestle friday i'm like i don't want to
wrestle on friday dude
i'm not about to go on stage like just
wrestle friday morning all right man
let's get it over with
can in san antonio no footage i did a
better job i handled it i did do a
better yeah i handled my
there yeah that's a nice picture i
appreciate it are you doing comedy are
you modeling and
i don't know i'm doing both a lot of
people say i got good like
a good chess ratio so i just wanted to
keep posting that
oh wow i appreciate you man do a lot of
people think that you
are um somebody's brother and it's the
wrong person yeah always
i always always get the uh it's always
two people right it's either lance gross
or michael b jordan wow and honestly i
don't look like
either one yeah have you ever seen
michael b jordan yeah exactly like he
was in friday night lights
yeah and the wire yeah that looks
[Laughter]
[Music]
i like that d plus a little bit theo i
thought we was both from louisiana you
could at least gave me a little higher
grade you're right man
i have a tendency to throw people under
the under the d plus
pretty good that was almost good
i have tendency to throw people under
the d-plus bus
um i just don't know what to say man
dude do you ever have them
i don't know man i sent an email before
this show that i definitely should not
have sent so this whole time i'm just
thinking god i wish i'd not
to me send that email
oh no because you know theo man if it's
before 9 a.m that email ain't gonna be
nice
it's gonna be vicious dude i just
checked my email it was
it wasn't me either oh no i'm gonna
if it's before noon it's it ain't nice
notes i don't answer the phone before 11
when you call it bro
this almost feels like an intervention
because everybody in here decide for you
yeah i've even before 9am and even
before
4 a.m
[Laughter]
if it's an early morning yeah or email
your god
[ __ ] and i called theo on it we started
arguing he was man my batman let's just
let's not
talk before noon anymore
and we don't i do some of my worst work
between the hours of 1 a.m
and 3 p.m
oh it's just like way i can feel like
other people at the end of this email
just getting
furious was it a business email
yeah yeah it was a business email man
[Laughter]
uh you're consumed with it though
yeah it's just like one of those things
it's just like weighing in my brain
anyway i didn't mean to bring it up i'm
not trying to sidetrack the show but i
wanted to just let you know what i was
thinking about no that's fair man you're
dealing with that you know
oh yeah it'll be fine man i just don't
like doing
it i'll tell you what's on my mind
i hate hollywood too but uh [ __ ]
college football
might not be going dude other
conferences are jumping out now
and what are they the lsu coach going
hard in the paint here yeah
yeah sec might just do their own thing
they should
mine as well what's the best political
now you look at you know the pac-12
bunch of [ __ ] mainly democratic
states
uh who else the big ten the big ten big
tens
but then ohio state was like all right
we'll just go play somewhere else
exactly they did yeah they're like we'll
jump in the sec
nebraska was like oh you want to cancel
we'll jump with the sec
so you might just get one baller ass
conference fine it'd be dope
finally man i wish that uh i wish that
some of the schools don't need to be
playing anymore no when connecticut was
like
connected was like i think we're out
this year like we don't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what is it what is the black community
saying about football are you guys there
we don't we still good you guys are good
yeah 100
but i mean we're on and off because og
obj he just said uh it should be
we should be banning football this year
really like a lot of black obj
yeah yeah he was like we shouldn't be
playing the guy that killed uh odell
beckham
said we should cancel football yeah well
for one he's on the cleveland browns so
let's just add that in
and two right so yeah who and two he's
so they're already
taking it easy if they on that team
correct and but i'm saying a lot of
black lives he was like yo
he's trying to like care about the
players i was like you got helmet and
gloves on you can't catch it
right and if you catch it you can
probably get rid of it
you can get somebody else's blood if you
want you know what i'm saying
there it is yeah a lot of players these
days it's like they don't even want to
be players anymore they want to be
players for the clout but they don't
want to be players
you mean everyone wants to be calling
kaepernick and actually or
everybody yeah or people turn in a
little bit more of an activist i feel
like sometimes
but i don't know maybe they're also
really scared i mean black and latino
people get that does get
by the chronovirus if you're in shape
though yeah if you're in shape they they
get it and they
they pass it you know it's not it's not
that big of a deal the kids in college
are more likely to die
driving to the campus than from corona
oh wow yeah and you got a little
nick nick saban said their players
they're safer
at uh alabama than at home because you
can get it from a bar
hanging out but all these these
bitch-ass owners who
are not owners but like the the regents
and all that who
who run the colleges they they know
what's going to happen they just if one
person dies they don't want it on their
hands
that's all they don't give a [ __ ] about
it but if you go to college somebody you
know dies man
somebody's dying bro by going to college
some parents send their [ __ ] kids to
college be like this little
we don't even care about this you don't
let that kid join a frat yeah do you
worry about colorado
you see what the frat boys do
eating dog eating dog food yeah
damn damn that's what they do i don't
know i never went through it but i know
those boys get saucy
well they die all the time well they
yeah because they freaking party hard
bro
the hardest yeah that's as hard as you
can party you die yeah you're right
that's game over but did you die and
they're like yeah yeah
yeah yeah my friend did god
have a few friends that did yeah they
were pledging and alan died
troy died
yeah dude troy passed away the worst is
when somebody's naked
yeah brett did pass away
the worst is it for somebody named troy
they uh
call themselves t-roy t-roy
roy went too hard big brother t-roy
yeah t-roy is bad what do you think ari
what are you what are you hearing uh
on the spectrum over there about um
uh see my family were just a little it's
scary to look at it's dangerous
football is a pretty dangerous like ct
yeah ct i mean i it's fun to watch but i
would never play it did you play you
were in military school did you guys
play in military school they had a team
we were actually it was mandatory to go
to the game so i would watch every game
and yeah the whole time just like ah
that was military
school did you go to college too yeah
what's you see santa cruz banana slug oh
she went the opposite way military to
hippie
and banana slugs are racial slur now
also isn't it it could be
yeah like an asian thing i'm not sure i
wasn't even thinking about that but now
yellow right yeah you could pick any
color almost and call them a banana
sauce
now your school got famous from pulp
fiction yeah that shirt uh
do you so do you think anything about
football
i don't watch it i'm not going to sit
here and pretend like i follow football
so you don't care if it happens or not
no yeah i say let it happen i want
things to be like normal yeah
so i think if it happened before i want
it to happen yeah what about
was nashville normal let me see compared
to l.a
because la is the worst right yeah
things were more open there things were
more open
uh you could go to restaurants um
i went and swam in like a lake out at
this place piercy priest park
where you just pull up and just like
remember that lake we swam in oklahoma
uh-huh
uh just like that kind of place so you
just pull up dirty fat kids
yeah nice
some kids have their shirts on yeah some
kind of shirts on yeah i love that
a lot of kids are shirts they should all
leave them on it especially in today's
time with like
yeah with comedians
i just want kids that should be a rule
kids have to keep their shirts on at all
times
um yeah i'm trying to think so yeah went
out to some restaurants did you eat
did you get any good nashville uh oh
yeah chicken hot sandwiches
i went to this place called edly's what
it was called there's some real famous
place out there italy's east that's what
it's called nick italy's east
and i got a straight-up east infection
in my stomach
dude yeah oh that's barbecue yeah i'm
talking about that natural hot chicken
scent oh
uh dave's eye chicken no not dead and
the boss boy there is a fan of the show
landon shout out landon a little ginger
a little sun
yeah this guy yeah little fella
he was over there yeah i forget the name
it's right downtown though it's right in
the city there's
chick nashville chicken hot sandwiches
remember yeah what's up
that's what you call it there's a line
up the goddamn door colin raised right
helen ray's
oh the one here in chinatown yeah it's
helen race no this place
there's also a national hockey b's for
[ __ ] sakes
how do you be patty b holland raises
here now
bees is um it's a lot like two hour line
yeah and i just got a call for pickups
for hot chicken
it's fantastic the best hot chicken you
have i think howling bees
but what do you mean hot raised here's
what i understand yeah what they mean
hot chicken i'm talking about that deep
fried chicken breasts
doused in hot sauce bro with pickles a
bun
wash it down with a nice dr pepper maybe
a big red i don't know today's sponsor
yeah bro you losing your hair you got
some erectile dysfunction you got a cold
how about you need some coven 19 home
test well him
said
66 of men start to lose their hair by
age 35
check yep check not really but it's
going into my eyebrows whatever
listen hams helps you guys thanks to
science hair loss can be optional
brendan
let me tell them i have erectile
dysfunction
okay i have lost my hair i've seen hair
in the sink hair in my bed
i don't know in a cat what's happening
limp wiener lamp wiener i've woken up in
the middle of the night and
shined a light on my wiener and seen it
sleeping on my thigh and then wake up
get up yeah map's over you've been
napping for weeks yeah and i'll put a
thing of soap in a sock and beat it with
it like yeah like a metal
like full metal jacket yeah you want
don't full metal jacket your dick
anymore man
use hymns right now few quick questions
with a real licensed medical
professional
and for free they'll do all that and see
if you get fda approved products to
treat hair loss
and your erectile dysfunction they
approve it and it shows up at your
doorstep
a little package discreet package if
you're not happy dude after 90 days
just email him you get a full refund
yeah and look here's the thing guys
you want to take the best chance you can
to have good wiener to have good hair
you want to take that best why wouldn't
you put your best foot forward
yeah would you give a child a vitamin
then give you a wiener a little vitamin
go to for hims.com
kats that's for hims.com
cats full refund of price paid available
for first 90 day supply refund requests
must be made between 90 and 20 days
after product shipping
prescription products require an online
consultation with a medical professional
who will determine if the prescription
is appropriate restrictions apply to
website full details and important
safety information
i've always wanted to do that let's
start dips
yeah let's get into this show man thank
you guys for joining us today
thank you for having me we already uh
watched one cats in a while theo
actually sent me this one he caught me
it's at the end of this video uh my
short stint as a server
[Music]
god damn
[Music]
[Laughter]
she comes
oh this is girl
[Music]
oh my soul's violent this is how people
die in college
[Laughter]
short stint it looked like they tried to
make a really cool video and just gave
up like we're gonna show all the
messages that [ __ ] was dope yeah it
started off really hot and it got weird
and let's focus in one more time on nick
losing his job at a fridays
so what happens is one kind of tip see
there boop
[Laughter]
episode
can't even imagine i sent that email
you gotta show me that e-book dude i
can't wait
okay oh another frat party yeah i like
that oh yeah who is this
is steven what's his name randolph in
the middle down there
this is a king at her stinger hey theo
hey brandon i've got a king of the
stinger for you
themed birthday parties it's my 25th
birthday party
we're going to toga party king it or
sing it
see now first of all this kind of stuff
needs to happen more often i think
with the chicks i agree i agree i don't
know maybe we should bring them into the
culture corner yeah
that looks funny we're not bringing
women into a corner at this time
right but let's bring them into an open
area we'll make a cultural open
area that's fair sorry but yeah it does
it shouldn't we got to change that
culture college
culture couch
that's even worse yeah that's work and i
think that name's taken on new porn
you can't have the culture lounge boom
culture
lady friendly done sound yeah it's too
you want to come over to our lounge full
of culture oh that sounds exotic
that sounds nice it does actually yeah
it's something
it's not a bad name for a comedy club
the culture lounge yeah pretty good the
same black club the ceo
yeah the ceo i'm going to king
uh toga parties yeah hell yeah
now i'm sure everyone there i what state
is that in i'm sure everybody got corona
which isn't a big deal because they're
young but
could be fun they did not say i don't
know
you're still worried about that email
huh yeah you think it's going to ruin
your career what are you thinking here
i don't really have that much of a
career but
i didn't do this one that well though
the other side is clean
ah they're both pretty good actually it
looks pretty good i'd let you come here
can you
oh he got hair it'd be weird though i
think it'd be weird me and brendan
talked about maybe
cutting his hair but then actually
imagining me cutting his hair
putting my hand on his head a little
weird
i mean what don't put your hand on his
head just cut it you have to here you
have like a barber
you gotta wear a gl yeah maybe wear a
glove or where uh you know wrap your
hand inside
can you can you deal with long hair can
you deal with this i do all hair i could
do even
alex's hair hold on now what do you mean
even yeah what are you talking about
hair from the bible yeah we do aries
here
hairs a little get a little curly
malik's oh that's crazy you guys do have
similar hair huh yeah we both know
i got i'm half white you guys are bible
smell creole creole is like white right
i don't know oh i don't even know dirty
rice kind of
yeah yeah yeah you guys are like bible
from the bible right ari and malik yeah
oh that is
very biblical names i don't know where
my name is does it
r means lion it means lion and jew
hebrew lying about what
[Laughter]
already brought this lady to the comedy
store sorry man
but there's a little more room oh what
is this about to be there's a little
more room under this bus
[Laughter]
remember that girl you brought the
comedy store that the cops came in you
heard about that
what do you mean yeah i think he made a
whole video about it
the cops came and picked the girl up
well so i was talking this girl on the
internet
like i do oh like i do from time to time
like we all do let's be real here oh
yeah like
everyone here doesn't i'm in trouble for
it she's not underage i like what she's
loving
so she met me at the commission patio
for a glass of wine
and then when she gets there she
explains to me that she is a lady of the
night
she's a pro she's a pro and i didn't
realize that and you had no idea
no idea and she was also very drunk when
she got there okay
she started trying to make out with me
hell yeah as well as
some other comedians that were on the
patio she was just a very social young
lady she's a social butterfly yeah she
was lovely nice kind
so i decided to go hide in the kitchen
in the back and
stay away from this person because it
scared you because i didn't want to be
associated with it
but i also didn't have the courage to
kick her out did you make out with her
at all
i can't remember i can't remember yeah
wow so i went to the kitchen and then as
i'm in the kitchen
she proceeds to cause a bigger scene and
get more drunk
on the patio on the patio curtis the
security guard comes
tackles her she calls him the n-word and
bites him
cops come and he's white he's white yeah
yeah
so wow i'm gonna use the n-word
yeah she was white so the cops come and
as the cops are resting her in handcover
she goes where's
arie where is arya i'm here with ari and
i'm just hiding the kitchen i don't know
what
that lady i don't know who that is
meanwhile five other aries who are
attorneys in los angeles
that happened to be on the porch showed
up and gave her their business
and uh yeah i had to make an apology
video to the comedy store staff
and a few others but i'm sure people
forget we have yeah do we have that
video
please do the video is pretty good you
still have it right
uh it's somewhere else was she an
attractive young lady yeah
yeah she was cute weird wow she was cute
and she was dropping
and i hope she was doing better i hope
that she got her alcoholism under check
and i wish you're nothing but the best
and probably
don't drop the n-bomb you know yeah yeah
i hope she's less racist now as well
have you heard the n-word less as you've
gotten older in your life do you feel
like or did you hear it much growing up
really no i listen to rap
so i uh i hear i hear a demon every day
uh but nah i never had somebody like a
different race call me their words in my
face
never never i think i'm like one of the
ready ones well
we don't let
i'll tell you this bro if you do say it
it's not going to end well for you
i'ma go viral i don't say that anymore
dude not anymore
nobody nah nobody really uh oh no nah
nobody called me the n-word but i
i hear i watch these videos like sean
king i go in there and i just see like a
different person saying i'm like where
are they at
i'm looking for him yeah i just want to
talk to him a little bit yeah
yeah getting there getting inside their
mind a little bit like
what n word and i'm like yeah yeah
yeah i don't i guess yeah i i i think i
i think you don't see as much of it
anymore you got to really go
almost looking forward i feel like you
know and i grew up in the south so yeah
yeah at least like every day you should
be like at least
get called on the way to school but
never nobody never really did that
one that's what i'm saying what about
even in the gym in the boxing gym never
never like even in black because i boxed
nobody ever said damn well that yeah
people if you box people definitely
aren't going to call you it well they
didn't know our boss but even even oh
yeah yeah even
well i seen somebody at the different
race like getting to it in floyd
mayweather's gym
and he was getting beat up it's like a
lot of black people i think he was like
uh like a ukrainian a guy and he was
getting everybody was just playing
laughing at him getting beat up
he was like man f all you n words and
then yeah double
devil and then he jumped down and he i
thought it was about to pop off
and the dude's about to get beat up
again i slept he just walked out the gym
i was like
oh yeah that's me uh i was preparing for
mike tyson i'm trying to fight him yeah
and who's that tall drink of water
you're uh tall drink a whiter who is
that dude that's johnny mitchell that's
uh
what's he do besides not box
he looks terrified dude he's like
he looks like he has a bunch of sugar in
his hand and threw me off because i
didn't want to buy some he don't have
any
draws on like he just has basketball
shorts i'm like yo come on like
he took his shirt off he really wanted
to do it but what who is it he fights
again
[Laughter]
he's a tall comedian yeah wow he fights
again and is he australian no no
no he's uh he's from boston i have so
many questions
the chest here yeah yeah who instigated
this well me
oh there he is right there with a gun in
his mouth yeah yeah that's
what that's my friends i hang around
and i'm looking for it inward that's
your boy yeah it's my boy nice guy
funny guy yeah why don't you blow his
head off there
that's crazy man blowing your own
with all head guns out there you think
you'd let somebody else do it you know
it's really it's really ineffective too
people mess it up all the time
yeah and then you miss your jaw yep and
then you're you gotta they bring you
back to life and then you're all
deformed but you're still living you're
still
sad who's this gentleman
what up brennan what up theo robert
coming at you
a few thousand feet underground this
gold mine
shout out to my hard hat hitters got a
king
jewelry gold jewelry talking about
necklaces bracelets watches
rings don't have a gold one i got this
rubber one so i don't get my finger
ripped off
but uh kangaroo sting it gold jewelry
gang gang bling bling bling bling
bling and restless too you forgot
wristlets other type of jewelry
neck uh nose piercings never thought
about piercing that sucker
dude i might hang a spare key off the
front
if i if i did i would hang it probably a
spare key that [ __ ] cause i always lose
my key
i gotta get a keychain i'm gonna king
jewelry obviously i wear jewelry really
hell yeah i love it love it never had
any pair you never had you've had
you look like the dude's had both ears
pairs oh yeah i have but i do have them
both here as pierce yep
but only because it's all spring break
yeah
only because it's spring break forever
and part of my part
dude we had this kid named billy and he
was he was an alcoholic he might still
be if he's still alive but
he um and this kid named
not billy conforto my friend that died
this is a different guy
and he on spring break broke um
he like broke his arm through a window
or something and then
he got arrested and so we had to bail
him out so we sold all of the stuff he
brought to spring break we sold it out
on like the strip
and did you make what i mean what did he
have that people wanted to buy like your
swim trunks and [ __ ] yeah clothes
he had a mask he had a couple just
not that much um
like a swimming water mass you know
water doesn't hit your face
hit your eyes oh like uh like he was
gonna snorkeling gear like snortly
yeah smart but he did yeah we didn't
make enough we made like seventy dollars
and spinning on beer and he stayed in
jail for like a week
but we had a plan i remember the
beginning of that day we had this big
plan we're gonna sell his stuff we're
gonna get him out of jail
and then by the end of the day uh one of
our girlfriends ended up banging that
guy tone lok because he was there
performing
oh oh gee oh geez what was his
main song he had that deep voice right
yeah yeah
oh then uh uh i just remember from
poetic justice
no but tone looks also in fern gully
there he is
he's the lizard in fern gully you said
uh he's also
in uh
you said one of our girlfriends which
one of your girlfriends tell them look
um
one of our girlfriends i don't want to
say her oh wow
yeah yeah yeah
one the wild thing has had more
busted people having sex to it than
anything else in the world
oh more tragic humans have [ __ ]
banged the wild thing
dude you've never seen him rap as the
lizard and cole medina
he was bad man he's the lizard and
friendly you're going to hell
hot rap dude i just love his voice man
yeah
one thing led to another yeah oh dude
check out this lizard dropping [ __ ]
bars
what's fern gully dude that's awesome
avatar stole the
it reminds me of the jockets i have
going on right now that's for sure
praise god look at that fat ass lizard
thick boy lizard mm-hmm
it's the story of avatar avatar stole
their idea
they stopped fern gully really yeah i
read the book i feel like can i wear
these hell yeah
you're probably cooler than him god damn
yeah you look like a wrestler man
you look like you about to just dive off
the top rope swan time looks like you're
about to do a ted talk on rice krispie
treats
[Laughter]
talking for
[Laughter]
that came straight out of like asia
what else you got nick that's a dope
dude am i the only one who [ __ ] with
fern gully
i'm the only one huh i don't remember i
was a little kid nick knows what's up
dude also nick's picks he's been killing
it for your boy on the picks me and him
before every fight
i'm not using expects anymore i put him
why you should though
70 but when you and i did use his picks
we lost a lot of money
last two ufc cards seven oh and one and
the draw was a plus 250 underdog so
he's part he's part of my show now
beating nick's picks and giving it to
these little [ __ ]
damn give him the picks i just want
people to know that like if you tail me
tail at your own risk i don't want
shitty dms i'm just
i watch every fight i'm a degenerate
gambler i think i have kind of an eye
for it but no i told them
this is nothing official yeah well
people use a picker because i think
sometimes
it's like it's better than having to
make your own choice almost but
nick and i'll give him the credit like
he looks into like the under cards
yeah all that [ __ ] where i'm just i just
go through the main card [ __ ] i have my
picks on the main card but that's it
you always ask me about my thoughts on
the main betting and like
betting is a bad idea vegas just knows
those lines you know you can't p
dc stipe it's minus one fifteen eight
eight
eight
eight
eight
eight
eight
seven yeah you're gonna lose money like
i don't
you're guessing it's a coin flip so
we'll send nick mean deal
uh now aria you wrestle in high school
absolutely not
what did you do my parents wouldn't even
let me do that if i wanted to what what
kind of
i played baseball on a little tennis
yeah
a little tennis dude i wasn't good
enough to make the team sound like
somebody got molested bro
little tennis until gary you got one two
hands
one day in short shorts no more tennis
thanks man they look better on you i
think really yeah
let me put them back on i think you're
underselling yourself men are
overselling yourself
yeah they probably do look a little
better oh here's you dude
i was just about to say you look like
him damn that's what i looked like
hey brandon hey theo what do you think
of bears [ __ ] in your backyard it's your
own national geographic [ __ ]
gang gang bear [ __ ] oh
he has two black beards doing black
saiyan
and look at that oh what a cool backyard
yeah that's a gift
and if you see a black animal do you
relate differently to a black animal
since you have a darker skin
yeah i kind of root for them yeah i feel
that
yeah it's like family feud when
you always do man yeah damn that
the gift of black bears in your backyard
man and doing sex
too man damn my buddy's dog used to do
sex with every dog and we would take it
down to the park and just watch it just
that sounds like a nice day oh we'd be
down there for old ones yeah
people would come in with their dogs
thinking that he wasn't going to try to
bang it in this dog weekend
right pink rocket comes out every time
man
i mean flash rocket oh we're about to
see it
apollo skirt teen dude
this thing was hunting leg dawg
[Laughter]
i love how you got just got in position
yeah yeah
trying to look uh [ __ ] right there
he's like oh i just had a shower
he just cleaned me that dog was trying
to look dang delectable
[Laughter]
what else you got nick what do you want
to see what do you want relationship
advice yeah what do you want us to do
nick
oh yeah we would love some more
relationship advices
uh send in videos of your aunt if you do
flop my aunt
uh videos of your clown my hounds we
have a couple of clown my hounds but
yeah
always send in videos not just images
we're not going to read
what you said i'll tell you what i can't
stop listening to that little brows
[ __ ]
king the sting rap he did that [ __ ] was
would you just post it that was hot
on that what's popping he floated he
floated
and there's drake right there
she gonna fire for question uh she i
mean it's just clown my hound
she's got some information on him oh
short thick hound there man
oh yeah we can adopt that short fat dog
that's that little that little milk
shake she was just showing that he rolls
down the window but she said uh
some [ __ ] dumped her in the country
and she found her on the streets it's a
beagle lab basset hound mix that's 13
years old and smarter than most kids all
right oh your award's in the mail lady
what do you want us to do it's kind of
like drinking
it's kind of like drink career a little
bit yeah so the the animal's been
through a tough time
and she picked them up that's easy
though
yeah he seems like a cool ass hound just
chilling in the car
yeah it seemed like he's doing fine what
happened to him
he can roll down the window he's
evidently really smart well here's the
thing what that
liverweight first of all why he's
missing was his own freaking fault
obviously
he's that smart he's able to roll down
the window dude
somebody didn't lose him he freaking
escaped obviously yep
damn so really he wants to leave lady
i think is what's going on so this is a
video of a failed kidnapping it sounds
like
a successful one we're like first 48.
we're like the first four yeah that's
man i hate the first 48. you hate it why
it's always in new orleans yeah no wait
well no it's in memphis first yeah yeah
i'm about to say memphis and oklahoma a
lot in miami
a lot of oklahoma used to be yeah tulsa
yeah there's a lot of snitching yeah i
knew as soon as they got the only way
they can
know all they have to do is just say i
want to talk to my lawyer so is the guy
put his worms in his t-shirt
i'm like he about to snitch and they
bring them back now they've gone there
all day but you realize cops can't do
[ __ ] unless people snitch
yeah all they do is try to get people to
snitch man they have no evidence nothing
i just i know that little ronnie
like haven't you seen the first four
thank you that's all i want like bro
just shut up
and then they just get them in and they
grill them in and next you know like man
listen
i wasn't driving the car and it always
starts off like that
and then they got him and they just walk
around and celebrate and they got him in
48 hours yeah
another brother gone damn yeah what was
chris's joke on first 48
oh yeah talia has the best joke he said
yeah the show is
it's about how police have the first
four have they have 48 hours to solve a
crime but really they have as much time
as they want
it's never in 48. like six months later
dude i think of that joke twice a week
that joke pops
yeah how funny it is me too yeah so
ridiculous
here's a guy right now who gave up on
his dreams to have a child
[Laughter]
look at that kid looks like amy schumer
yeah like it's about to snitch on a
fellow comedian for something it didn't
do
she must have a lot of room under her
bus
you do not want to be friends with her
because it's coming man yo look at this
that baby definitely
from brandon uh it's matthew from canton
georgia
and me and my girl have a debate club
we were just watching you guys um
so the power rangers team or
the captain planet team captain planet
has them hearts so our money's on uh
the captain planet team but uh what do
you guys think
gang gang buzz buzz oh dude i know you
look like captain planet but uh
the power rangers went hard in the paint
thank you when i was a kid
it was all day power rangers mighty
morphis
now it gets a little the new power
ranger a little weak they're all
politically correct
half of them are women they made the
black ranger not black anymore yeah no
way because that was racist they made
the yellow ranger not asian like
i guess the black ranger is cool now he
blew blue yeah
it's on ouch both of those suck how
about that
my kid's not into that gay [ __ ] bro
yeah yeah man so sting them both
in the debate club what did uh
what did the guy want to know what was
wrong with that what do you what what
was better as a kid
power rangers or captains i never got
into captain i never got there
there's always an agenda as a kid i was
like what are they trying to sell me on
doug i'm good
yeah it always litter come on yeah it
always felt like it was about litters
or like saving a rain forest or some
kind of [ __ ] or the planet
yeah i'm trying to dude it's saturday
morning
i'm going to eat my series i'm trying to
watch ren and stimpy animania
i'm trying to kill time until i hit
purpley and i'm down to [ __ ] you know
that's how i'm doing it and helping this
boner y'all
what's the yellow thing what's the
yellow thing in his chest a planet oh
what planet captain planet that's a good
point
yeah yeah i don't know what yellow
planet
um but thanks for sending in him man
that's a beautiful child you got your
super cute kid whoa you found us
the boys we're on patreon now yeah king
and the sting king this
staying that man we're here on patreon
so
welcome to the patreon and this is you
know extra if somebody wants extra then
you this is it are you jonesing for more
king of the sting
well you found it and we got three
options for you yup we got the lightning
and the honey right here they got
uh touch me don't touch me keep
touching me meet me at 20. meet me at
20. baby they got three tiers
you can check them out and uh see
whatever fits for you
and um bonus episodes yeah no commercial
ads for
regular episodes we got merch offers we
got 360 camera
you up for that that head on a swivel
appeal you know that lazy susan
that owl yeah you get that oh that's
the album that's alertic bruh um
but yeah there's something for you if
you want it and so
no obligation but here it is and thank
you for supporting uh king and the sting
enjoy what's up theo brennan and gang i
got y'all playing right here
got a debate club for you all right
would you rather be
short like really short or
freakishly tall tall now mind you you
might think
okay uh tall obviously right
i'm six nine so i know what kind of that
you can't find shoes can't find clothes
can't go on airplanes traveling
sucks let me know what you all think
gang gang buzz buzz praise god brother
praise god i praise god
yeah jesus christ ori you came in hot
with this one what do you think man
oh tall all day you can't find shoes
that fit go to a store
go to the internet that's easy no you
don't find anything cool though like you
like you hold up any any designer shoe
the the max limits usually like 15. you
know you want to know what's cool
getting laid is cool really short yeah
you don't get laid it's all he cares
about is getting laid but here's
a big portion you need cool cars name of
cool clark you ain't fitting in
suvs you gotta drive that's what this
guy's putting into the walls of a van
right now
okay i'm saying when he's older more
successful you're right man get an suv
get a pickup truck you can't drive uh
again
cool car what about ferraris lambos
porsches mclaren's
sacrifice i'm willing to make but here's
the thing and then the airport thank you
that's what i'm saying first class
you're [ __ ] everything's southwest
when you're six nine come on man and he
got a great voice
so were y'all saying little or big i
don't know what y'all are saying i'm
saying
you're saying little ah man little
something too little
no chick digs a real short
what about that guy with no legs who
shot his wife to death
who's that i didn't hear about that
taurus or whatever yeah in australia
remember that guy he's a champion runner
big runner yeah yeah blade runner blade
right here
try playing sports when you're really
short not fun lacrosse
ufc um yeah
155 and under you killing it one sport
uh jockey jockey okay you win
yeah there's not really i mean there's a
short baseball player what's the name uh
a tuve the guy who just
went for houston yeah yeah yeah i mean
cheater but yeah
yeah but he want mvp and he's short but
if you're tall a you're gonna get more
ladies probably have a bigger ding-dong
let's be real
but here's the thing imagine you show up
with that little baby jingle bell and
you're six
five baby like shaq huh jack has a tater
tot it's well known
but i don't know i've heard that shaq
has a real heat stick on him no that's
not true
really first of all i didn't hear that
neither one of us know and
that's good so i'm not gonna drop in
some facts
i'm just not gonna argue about i don't
wanna ever
us to look back our children look back
and know here's my dad and
my dad's lying arguing about how big a
man's penis is
when you're right you're right i just
look at look how small he is though
yeah but here's anything but i'm saying
if you're real tall and you got that
little baby jingle bell dog that thing
is gonna
disappoint you ladies even just grabbing
it with your hand trying to get it like
trying to get a grape out of a big dish
yeah think about what your [ __ ]
meat eaters are yeah big old dick
beaters you reach down there you get
that little
tater tot oh like trying to pick a
butterscotch out of dang garbage bag
bruh
you guys are all tall it's easy for you
to say the cons of being tall you all
got it i'm not tall
you're six foot six foot that's probably
pretty good for good size
i'm getting shorter you're good size
you're like wrong look how five nine i
used to be average now i'm below average
the new average is five ten
tom cruise is five nine i think he's
even he's five he's like five six
every rapper is yeah anyway like so
that's and they get laid a lot so i'll
rather be short every rapper
but five nine isn't short sure when he
said really short that's five
four five six real short would be five
the baby the baby is five two
one three he's a rich rapper that's what
i'm saying i'm saying and grand scheme
like what are what are we talking about
if you're
yeah exactly five two how tall go on
grinder good luck exactly if you're an
accountant what height do you want to be
if you're a plumber what height are you
not if you're if you want to be 60 do
you want to go to the bank teller any
six
nine like what a terrible
look at that man every rap lil wayne is
five five
lamar five six and you gotta stand yeah
peter dinklage
four foot i mean five eight bro
eminem five eight yeah i didn't realize
i didn't know that you know he was
taller i meant some good company kanye
is five eight as well
louisiana had some height uh how how
tall is silk the shocker oh he's six
foot
oh master p was tall too he played
basketball five eight
yeah they played basketball you talking
about athletes now now we're talking
about six
four silk the shocker yeah yeah yeah now
he died now
but he died shocker if you're short you
live long
yeah wait wait wait no or does he see
murder no jail but he's in jail where
he's mystical
they're all alive brendan all my heroes
are still alive
those are your heroes yeah they're my
partners in crime they might i think
some of those guys are dead
have you watched the no limit uh
documentary nah i heard it's good though
yeah
but i'm kind of sad no limit was they
were talking about their height bro this
is a tall batch of fellas right there
yeah
not like these other short ass rappers
from other places how tall is paul wall
five i'm gonna say five seven okay
but he seemed pretty tall i think he's
like paul walden no no no no
the brad is little oh six foot yeah see
yeah
yeah damn slim thug six six
oh that's a big one here's the thing
though if you lift you got a if you got
a small height
yeah if you got a small height then you
have
more chip on your shoulder i think you
might have more drive you might have a
little more combustion in your with you
that's what i'm saying i agree with you
yeah because if you're stretched out
you're long you might be more like oh
everything's
easier yeah chicks coming your way
and chicks and dude also my grandfather
there i am last night actually with a
yellow woof yellow wolf
he's tall yellow one that was last night
yeah what were you guys doing
uh and gangsta boo right there um
i like yellow wolf yellow he's great and
that lady was in three six mafia too
the bride gangster boo boo that's not
the brat
notice damn juicy j in three
uh
and who else were they talking to on the
phone that was pretty fun
yellow is only six foot he looks taller
than that booger chucky or something
some man named booger chucky
um but anyway what are we saying
we're talking about small and height
like you said you're small guys
it's not a thing dude first of all were
you at a concert
no they were in studio i just went to
hang out for a little while oh word
booger chucky is the craziest name i
feel like
it doesn't sound real dude everybody had
that kid in class though who was a
straight booger chucky dude
who would pick his nose and look like he
was going to kill people later on in
life bro
we had one kid i swear this boy named
michael bro
he always had one one finger in his nose
and one
eye on your [ __ ] heart
a little booger
booger chucky bro cause chucky's a
little killer think about that
chucky was a killer how tall is chucky
look at us
yeah that's right he's like two six i
think
but let's see they did a new one heard
some [ __ ]
chucky doll height 29 inches dude two
five i was one injured
you know you're right hey bro and i bet
600 on it
dude you telling me little can't be bad
ass little chucky's little ass
29 inches of straight [ __ ]
silverware murder board
okay yeah so you all need to get it
right all of you out here
and look if you're tall you can't be a
[ __ ] murderer you can't
it's you know easy i agree i didn't seek
you busted you ain't doing
[ __ ] everywhere you go you gotta do like
this to make sure you don't hit a
[ __ ] shitty light at some point
people always ask you to grab things for
them people meeting up at you at the
fairgrounds people all let's meet over
there by randall you're digging
everybody's face all the time like a
microphone yeah you got to put deodorant
on the side of your nuts because of
where your nuts are in space to people's
heads
stuff you gotta think about man dude you
gotta think more
little you show up nobody gives a [ __ ]
anyway you wanna be tall ari after all
that
absolutely come on man i never did those
things i don't know what height
that imagine only be able to have 11
people at your church
if you're tall you could be a hero you
could save people out of trees and stuff
i've always wanted to be a hero
who's a little hero chin well your whole
your whole
culture that's true i mean before me the
people before me
yeah but not anymore not anymore now
we're getting real tall you're that game
breaker bro yeah
i am literally out of my whole family
you're the tallest asian i've ever seen
thank you appreciate it you're the
tallest asian i actually knew a guy
this was on a ship though you're the
tallest asian on land that i know
that's fair in person was it cruise ship
to
land asian yeah this was cruise ship
you're i mean you're the the kemi
mutumba of koreans
but they're getting taller than me now
so i was like i was like the threshold
breaking point
and now there's like getting super small
you have to have kids
oh now that they're taller not really
all right man i'll be fine
who's a little killer right there frodo
baggins right there
three six danny devito five four genghis
khan
was five one prince okay genghis khan
people he killed people were shorter
back then i think yeah
did didn't mugsy boge shoot somebody one
time he's five three no that was uh
marvin harrison killed somebody at a car
wall you're right
yes or it did by the way he still played
the following sunday no
picasa was 5'4 dude michael j
fox back to the future fight i know
kevin hart was that little
look at seth green's little last woody
allen little touch
harry potter is only five five
your favorite bruno mars not a little
damn jack black
only five six look at all the talent and
short people man
aziz five six a lot of people trying to
join five six yeah we're going to hell
man
[Laughter]
our tall ass is bro
martin luther king jr we're not even to
your height yet he's only five
seven robin williams five seven nothing
more but you know what i'm saying
tom cruise oh you said tom cruise is
five seven yeah
al pacino spud whip dunk contest
manny pacquiao yeah and how tall you
already five nine five nine
of these i'm feeling good it's making me
feel really good yeah yeah that's why we
brought you here
carlos they even include five nine i'm a
tall guy
yeah i'm one of you five nine's average
they call you stretch on this list
[Laughter]
what else you got nick that's it damn
how long was this episode
our five hour eight just got started i
know
that's what we do doug nice change of
pace after we freaking
kicked it through the after we just
punted the whole [ __ ] show on that
british we didn't know anything
i felt like such an idiot i was
listening to that trying to get a feel
for
what you guys do you watched the british
one you've never seen the show
yeah this is my first time you asked me
to do it i wanted to know
it's like i spent enough time with you
guys where i don't want to listen to you
in my free time
that's fair i wouldn't listen to it
either
um watch that [ __ ] but dude i just we
got to the part in that episode where
about british comedians we knew
three people if that i felt like they
had to bring it up yeah i cheated i
don't know on russell howard
i showed it to him you weren't looking i
feel like such an idiot
how do you think i feel my family's from
there i brought nothing to the table
i just kept saying fish and chips the
entire time
yeah that was bad yeah my mom my was not
not happy that was bad
yeah i just can't believe we don't know
anything more about other places dude
we're idiot
idiot we're idiots
i'm an idiot
i just gotta get better and i knew well
honestly man i knew
this is gonna sound messed up but you
gonna throw me under the bus you got
more room under there let me see
oh yeah we do have a little more room um
i knew that you weren't
you know the real cat's meow of the
library kind of sure
but i didn't know that i was that dumb
no you did it i'm glad we did it then
yeah yeah because i knew
i appreciate that bro that's why we're
partners
yep part life partners yeah sure man
whatever whatever you call it i got you
a present for having me on oh really
yeah for your kids oh thanks man yeah
oh yeah um i almost read this book once
oh damn that's cool man ari wrote it
is a safe book for the kids yeah it's a
children's book how old are they
uh the one who can read is a four and a
half perfect they're gonna love it
hell yeah thanks dude there's nothing
creepy in there now do this do you have
a bunch of these in your van
uh yeah i got a lot of them i keep them
in the van i keep everything i own in
the van
yeah it is warm it is super warm ari's
warm up
bears don't like candy that's what it's
called yeah yeah yeah but
four and a half stars yeah i got a few
haters
i actually got a lot of haters but uh
yeah it's just a book for kids
i've read this book yeah there's some
grammatical errors it's
i'm coming out with a sequel actually
that no one wanted but
it's uh yeah it's just a book for kids
and age
i'd say zero to four thanks man yeah i
hope they like it
we'll read it tonight and i'll report
back malik where can people check you
out
oh uh i bought a gift before uh i bought
a gift too for you
um you know miles from the live factory
yeah yeah
you know what this is shirts he told me
to give this to you so
i just wanted
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you are changing you have good
sized nipples for your body
thanks dude a little far apart though
yeah
the underarms is
as well
black people jewish people we all got
yeah everybody brought it together
yeah we brought it back together that's
what i'm saying man teamwork man
we wear each other it is cold under each
arm
i i got secret deodorant yeah yeah
you're good
that's what i'm saying bro that shit's
dope hey man
honored to wear the shirt off of my
brother's back yeah thanks for coming in
fellas
yeah so much thank you guys for coming
in
brendan and theo fighter and weight i
got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino every song i hit
like the great bambino burning ain't the
queso and the quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tried but couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up king
and a sting king oh yeah
king and the sting beast
[Music]
got the bees in the trap
[Music]
on a string